هذه ليست مجرده اوعيه بلاستيكيه عاديه هنا
يوجد نحو عشره الاف دماغ بشري لاشخاص غير
عاديين حفظت على مدار اربعين عاما واقدم
دماغ منها يعود الى نحو 78 عاما
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منا
عالم غريب
في الطابق السفلي من جامعه اودنسي
الدنماركيه مشهد يبدو عاديا لرفوف هذا
المخزن الواسع لكن هذه الاوعيه البيضاء
الكبيره تحتوي على حقيقه مرعبه
949 دماغا بشريا محفوظه في ماده
الفورمالين انتزعت على مدار اربعه عقود من
جثث لمرضى نفسيين في الدنمارك لغرض اجراء
بحوث تجريبيه عليها
البدايه كانت عام
1945 عندما قرر الطبيب النفسي المعروف
انذاك ريكسترون
الشروع في عمليه جمع كبير للادمغه الخاصه
بالمرضى النفسيين بعد تشريح جثثهم واستمرت
العمليه حتى بدايه الثمانينيات عقول
مرصوفه على الرفوف لقطات مريبه غير معتاده
لكنها في هذه الجامعه ربما تكون مالوفه
[موسيقى]
الدنمارك في تلك الفتره كانت تعتبر ان
المرضى العقليين يشكلون عبئا على المجتمع
وانهم قد يتسببون بازمات كبيره في حال سمح
لهم بانجاب الاطفال لذلك تم تعقيمهم بامر
القانون بين عام
1929 وعام
1967 كما ان فكره حمايه حقوق المرضى
النفسيين لم تكن سائده في ذلك الوقت وكان
الهدف الاساسي حمايه المجتمع منهم
اصحاب هذه العقول عانوا من الخرف والفصام
والاضطراب ثنائي القطب وغيرها من الامراض
لكن الاهتمام المتزايد بحقوق المرضى ادى
الى انهاء عمليه جمع الادمغه في عام 82
في عام 2018 نقلت مجموعه الادمغه هذه الى
جامعه اودينسي بعدما كانت لفتره طويله في
مدينه ارهوس غرب الدنمارك ويجري الان
العمل على اربعه مشاريع علميه
لمعرفه المزيد عنها
[موسيقى]